groupe
socialiste madame la Présidente mes
chers collègues on allait voir ce qu'on
allait voir le président a convoqué hier
soir les français pour je cite son grand
rendez-vous avec la nation mais sur quoi
unit-on une nation sur quelle vision
pour que la France reste la France pour
reprendre la formule sur
grandmour mais la France républicaine
n'est pas une nostalgie elle est horizon
la volonté chaque jour renouvelé
d'avancer sur le chemin de la liberté de
l'égalité et de la
fraternité les crises se multiplient
elle se cumulent les inégalités
explosent c'était le moment de
responsabiliser le CAC 40 avec un
discours de vérité en appelant les plus
riches à l'effort national pour répondre
au défis de l'avenir le voilà le vrai
réarmement civique l'école elle a besoin
de nouveaux usussard de la République
pas d'uniforme rendez à nouveau
attractif le plus beau métier du monde
soutenez l'école publique le travail il
doit payer il faut une grande conférence
sociale où tout serait remis à plat pour
augmenter les salaires à commencé par
les premiers de corvé le logement un
toit pour tous devrait être la règle
alors que plus de 3 millions de
logements restent aujourd'hui vacants
l'accès aux soins il est temps d'en
finir avec les désers médicaux de
réguler l'installation des médecins
comme c'est le cas pour les pharmaciens
la bifurcation écologique vos propres
experts ont exigé des moyens rétablissez
un ISF climatique la démocratie c'est
d'abord le pluralisme interd
tion des
Méar l'indépendance des
réac par vous monsieur Premier ministre
plusun mot vous ne pouvez pas être le
simple cabor d'
président merci monsieur le
député la
parole
madameole du gouvernement ministre en
char
renveaumocraque monsieur le député fort
j'avoue être un peu perplexe parce que
je m'attendais à une question et en
réalité j'assiste à un simulacre de
discours de politique général mais soit
allons-y
allons-y allons-y vous qui n'avez bien
évidemment vous qui n'avez vous qui
n'avez bien évidemment jamais été aux
responsabilités vous qui n'avez jamais
pu bien évidemment faire des choses pour
la France que ce soit ici ailleurs
aujourd'hui ou avant mais regardons les
sujets dans le fond parce que les gens
n'attendent pas qu'on crie mais plutôt
qu'on leur réponde et nous avons
aujourd'hui cette responsabilité de
pouvoir adresser des sujets de fond face
au défis auquels sont confrontés nos
concitoyens vous parlez de
redistribution et bien oui nous sommes
un des pays où il y a le plus de
redistribution et cette redistribution
elle existe parce que bien évidemment il
y a effectivement des personnes qui
peuvent distribuer et participer à cette
redistribution et cette solidarité
nationale ce n'est pas en pointtotin du
doigt qu'on y arrivera et ce n'est pas
en pointant du doigt qu'on arrivera à
créer la cohésion nationale dont nous
avons tant besoin en ce moment notamment
vous parlez d'augmenter les salaires oui
et encore oui monsieur fort oui mais
pour augmenter les salaires encore
faut-il que les emplois existe et c'est
ce à quoi nous nous sommes employés dès
2017 à lutter contre un fléo que vous
avez renoncé à travailler que vous avez
considéré comme une fatalité qui
s'appelle le chômage de longue durée et
le chômage de masse c'est une réalité
vous pouvez souffler nous l'avons fait
donc encore une fois je pense
qu'aujourd'hui même si vous faites
partie d'un groupe d'opposition nous
pouvons encore nous retrouver pour
travailler ensemble non pas pour
travailler sur les égos et faciliter les
gos mais pour défendre des idéos que je
pense un jour nous avions en commun je
vous remerci madame la
ministre